the conversation is over but oh it's
just beginning
Kylie Jenner took a break from playing
with mama Chris's creepy wax bigger to
actually hang out with the real life
Kris Jenner night out and the
mother-daughter duo are trying out new
ways to pass time in quarantine like
hopping on tick-tock are we cool like
are we in agreement on Monday Kylie and
Kris have blessed us by recreating an
iconic keeping up with the Kardashian
scene abcdefg I actually know what the
heck is ABCDE of cheering in case you
don't remember the infamous one-liner
let's back it up this is chill time you
work for me right now the og moment went
down between Kourtney and her ex Scott
Disick the two were arguing and court
decided to end the combo with the
alphabet so are we cool like are we in
agreement
abcdefg I have to know what the heck is
ABCDE of Jamie it's just a phrase I like
to use that means not a real friend the
conversation is over
naturally that moment went viral and
Kylie in Crested and waste any time
recreating the magic or we cool like are
we in agreement
abcdefg I actually know what the heck is
ABCDE of Jamie it's just a phrase I like
to use that means not a real friend the
conversation is over come on that you
absolutely nailed it I don't know it
would have come so naturally my mother
wasn't who she is
Kris killed it as confused Scott Disick
while Kylie played her sassy older
sister were we cool like are we in
agreement
abcdefg actually for added drama
Kylie slid on a pair of pearl studded
glasses and pieced out by chugging a
bottle of 1942 tequila that means a real
friend the conversation is over
but the Jenners aren't the only ladies
going down keeping up memory lane so are
we cool like are we in agreement
abcdefg actually no yep cara delevingne
and girlfriend Ashley Benson also nailed
it what the heck is abcdefg
it's just a phrase I like to use that
means not a real friend the conversation
is over
totally impressive work there but we
gotta say nothing beats the original
family their own spin to a that means
our real friend the conversation is over
[Music]